the new york post announces the big news
a baby
with three dads this is supposed to be a
a historic first a major milestone in
human history
and it certainly would be if there
actually existed a baby with three
actual fathers
turns out and this is no surprise to the
dwindling minority with a rudimentary
grasp of basic human biology
that the child merely has a birth
certificate with the names of three
dudes written on it
here's the post with the details it says
a gay polyamorous california thrupal
made history in 2017 when they became
the first family in the state to list
three parents on a birth certificate
their reproductive journey and legal
battle to become fathers to piper now
three
is detailed in three dads and a baby
written by one of her dads dr ian
jenkins
jenkins and his partners jeremy hodges
and dr alan mayfield
don't see their family which now also
includes their son
parker as unusual
well of course it is by definition
unusual
it's not possible for a thing to make
history and not be
unusual indeed unusual is the most
polite and measured thing
that i can say about this particular
arrangement
but more from the post it says jenkins
met mayfield a psychiatrist
while they were completing so maybe we
should tell you a little something about
the psychiatry industry
uh well anyway he met a psychiatrist
while they were completing their medical
residencies in boston the two were
together for eight years when hodges
who works at a zoo hospital came into
the picture although their relationship
with hodges began as a friendship things
quickly turned romantic after five years
of
throppledum the trio started seriously
discussing parenthood when friends
offered to
donate their leftover embryos to them
leftover embryos isn't it inspiring to
hear human life referred to this way
like it's a slab of meatloaf sitting in
a tupperware container in the fridge
i got some leftover embryos let me go
grab them i think i got a couple in the
trunk
i'll go i'll go take a look
as it turns out the leftover embryo i.e
human life
wasn't viable and the next attempt tempt
also didn't take so they took several
several tries just tossing out the
embryos no big deal it's just human life
finally um a helpful friend gave them
some of her eggs which
were then fertilized in a laboratory and
implanted in the uterus of another
friend
meanwhile some fancy footwork was
performed with the help with the help of
lawyers and
tens of thousands of dollars of legal
fees and then presto chango just like
magic
a child with three dads was born which
is to say
a child with one father a mother she'll
never know who was conceived in a petri
dish
brought to term in a rented uterus and
placed in the care of three men who
immediately set out to monetize her
existence with a self-congratulatory
memoir
was born tomato tomato i suppose
if you're feeling not terribly excited
about our new and improved society where
babies can have three dads and no mom
that's because you're a normal insane
person as a normal and
sane person the whole thing probably
seems to you rather
i don't know a natural disordered
you likely have the impression that the
interests of the children aren't being
taken much into account here sure
the men feel great about their dad trio
but their emotional needs aren't the
primary concern
of normal and sane people we're worried
about the children
who are being treated more as fashion
accessories than human beings
to respect their humanity is to
acknowledge that children need mothers
too
it is an absurd and damnable idea that
the role of the mother can be adequately
replaced
just by adding more dads into the
equation
i'm still not exactly sure what the
exchange rate is like you add uh
add you know so you have one dad that's
that's that equals
a dad and then you've got two dads that
equals a mom
so each dad equals one mom how does it
work exactly
add four more dads and you have two moms
a dad
but if adding dads is the plan why stop
at three why not four
dads four dads five dads six dads seven
it's beginning to sound like a creepy
children's book that i'm sure somebody
will eventually write
this is not a rhetorical question it's
something we really need to think about
because the floodgates are officially
open and have been for some time
one society moves away from the nuclear
family not just in practice
but in a categorical denial that it is
the ideal family structure at all
then there's no remaining boundary no
limiting principle
this is where the so-called slippery
slope argument comes in and it's why
those who warn about slippery slopes are
usually proven correct
even as the left laughs and guffaws at
the whole notion that perhaps sometimes
one thing might lead to another
i mean they call something a slippery
slope argument as if
simply labeling it slippery slope is
enough to uh debunk it it's not
yes oftentimes slopes are slippery
oftentimes one thing leads to another
the point with the slippery slope is
that when you tear down a boundary
without any idea as to where to rebuild
it
or you get rid of a words definition
without even a suggestion as to what its
new definition
definition ought to be then you have
obviously
that it would seem by design scent sent
this
new boundary-less undefinable thing
tumbling into insanity and incoherence
you haven't actually moved the boundary
or changed the definition of the thing
but simply destroyed it as i've observed
many times this is the process playing
right
playing out right now with respect to
gender we're told that the word woman
no longer means adult human female which
is what it meant since the dawn of time
so what does it mean if it's not that
then what is it those who seek to erase
the words
traditional definition have it turns out
no plans for giving it a new one
they don't seek to promote or you know a
new or expanded concept of womanhood
but to annihilate the very concept
itself
it is not really a slope but a free-fall
plunge into obliteration
each new stage in our moral and logical
descent
is predictable and inevitable if our
biological identity has no meaning and
can be changed on a whim
then the same will be done with age and
race and every other aspect of our
identity
it's not a question of if
it will happen it is already beginning
to happen
because there's no reason why it
wouldn't happen
now that the precedent has been set and
the logical and moral barriers
preventing it from happening have been
removed
and so with marriage and family it's the
same
we have seen three men call themselves
dead
soon that's not going to be the
strangest or most disturbing combination
give it enough time and even the
self-professed conservatives will be
defending the three dad concept as
valid and equal while maybe maybe
offering polite pushback to the newer
you know
four dads and three sex robots family
units
i wish i was exaggerating but this is
the path that we put ourselves on
when we moved away from the mother
father nuclear family structure
that was we had it right the first time
that was right
everything after that is wrong
and once you give up on that
there is no end the truth is that every
child needs and deserves both a mother
and a father
we have to preserve that or preserve
nothing
there is no middle option there is no
compromise with moral insanity
you either fight it with all you have on
every field of battle
never giving it a single inch or you
surrender
and let it have its way with the culture
and we have obviously in this culture
made our choice
and we chose very poorly well i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the matt wall
show if you
did go ahead and hit that subscribe
button right down there so you can stay
up to date on all of our future content